which actor's portrayal of the doctor
was so hated that the show was canceled
after a quarter of a century of success
keep watching to find out
this is more of an honorable mention
than a true ranking as john hurt was
made to play a grizzled veteran of an
intergalactic war he looks like he's
seen bodies floating in a vacuum and
he's going to do something about it the
war doctor's incredible backstory and
the time manipulation plot that allows
him to avoid destroying his homeworld is
a wonderful bit of world building but as
he never actually starred in a single
episode as the one true doctor it simply
doesn't seem fair to rank him with the
folks who have had their name on the
marquee even if he ultimately did a
better job than many of them
[Music]
poor paul mcgann never had a chance he
basically got one made for tv movie
which was intended to be a pilot for a
series that ultimately was never made in
terms of on-screen performances mcgann's
romantic frilly take on the doctor
amounted to little more than a footnote
in the long history of who which
relegates him to the bottom of the list
there is some consolation however as the
only official doctor between the
original series ending in 1989 and the
new version's debut in 2005 mcgann's
eighth doctor went on to have an
oversized presence in other media
appearing in novels comic books and more
than 70 audio dramas he finally got to
return to the screen for a final
farewell in the 2013 short the night of
the doctor which saw him die and
regenerate as hurts war doctor
colin baker was the doctor for several
years but that doesn't mean he was given
anything approximating a fair shake the
sixth doctor's tenure was marred by
behind the scenes drama as budget
shortfalls and other issues led to
shortened seasons and long hiatuses he
fought an uphill battle against an
unpredictable schedule and absolutely
insane costume struggling through
several seasons as the doctor as viewers
tuned in less and less reliably in spite
of all that strain baker did manage to
turn out one of the most memorable arcs
in the history of the series with the
trial of a time lord even with the death
of the series scriptwriter and other
off-screen catastrophes baker held down
the role admirably until being dismissed
after the series 23rd season fan love of
baker's tenure expressed itself in many
extended universe adventures fleshing
out threads that were abandoned when he
was removed from the roll
the doctor knows more about most things
than the people around him but he should
never be above it all that's a lesson
that sylvester mccoy and the creative
team behind doctor who learned the hard
way as they rode the series into the
ground mccoy's intellectual and
self-important take on the doctor rubbed
viewers the wrong way and they abandoned
the show in droves the bbc did the
formally unthinkable and put the show
out of its misery in 1989 to make
matters worse in the 1996 doctor who tv
movie the doctor was unceremoniously
killed by gang members in san francisco
playing into some of the grossest
aspects of media during the period's
crime panic
peter davidson filtered fellow doctor
tom baker's eccentricity through 80s
cool looking like don johnson from outer
space in his three seasons at the helm
of the tardis but the writers made the
interesting decision to rob the doctor
of his well-earned wisdom in spite of
his centuries of inherited memories
davidson's doctor was a bit of an
indecisive fop dropped on top of scripts
that hearkened back to the first
doctor's grave seriousness credit
davison's charisma and skills as an
actor for making doctor who work anyway
at the end of the day though workable is
all davison's tenure was he did a fine
job bringing some of the series main
antagonists back into popular
consciousness as seven full seasons
behind baker's wild stories had moved
the show away from battles with the
cybermen and the master davidson's time
was the last of the original who's high
ears sliding quickly without him into
the low point that led to the show's
cancellation
stern bombastic and grandfatherly
william hartnell launched the series and
is deservedly beloved for being the
first person to don that mysterious
moniker that lends us the title of the
show but no one thinks of him first when
they try to pull up the doctor cardinal
made the series a success allowing it to
continue well past its sell-by date and
stick in the brains of a younger
generation of creatives who helmed the
new who years for that alone he should
be praised but the series was a long way
from dinosaurs on a spaceship leaning
much more into the educational potential
of the show his stilted and cold take on
the traveling alien was more alien than
anything else and left the warm
human-loving parts to be fleshed out by
actors that followed
jodie whitaker knocked her performance
of the doctor out of the park she
stepped into the role as the first ever
woman to play the doctor and played it
so well that pitying her for the
misogynist backlash against her casting
feels unnecessary the doubters have been
proven wrong by how well she holds down
one of the most recognizable roles in
all of fiction whitaker swings the role
back from peter capaldi's standoffish
thrill seeker playing 13 as a bubbly and
friendly helper who loves humans as much
as she loves solving problems
unfortunately though whitaker's time as
the doctor has been dragged down by
scripts that haven't always lived up to
the show's high standards not the first
time a great doctor has been undermined
by creative choices outside their
control
i'm the doctor
what if the doctor broke bones as well
as he set them that's the conceit at the
heart of john pertwee's doctor a savvy
and dapper martial artist who isn't
afraid to set down his sonic screwdriver
and work with his hands instead
pertwee's tenure laid the groundwork for
a decade of high-energy action sequences
burtweed played the doctor as a scrapper
and a scientist making him equally quick
with a gadget as a fist the third doctor
was angry dude being forced to hang
around earth and he took out his anger
on any alien who got in the way of his
fists his tenure is an important
building block in several other ways
marking the first appearance of sarah
jane smith as a companion introducing
the doctor's nemesis the master and
reviving the daleks as primary
antagonists
still his tenure is firmly in the middle
of the pack reversed neutron flow or no
peter capaldi was previously best known
for his work as a foul-mouthed political
operative and fittingly he brought a
good bit of darkness back to the role in
his brief run as the doctor he played
the character with a cold remove amping
up the alienness of the time lord in a
way that hadn't been seen since the
original run of the show far from david
tennant's near romance with a human
capaldi's doctor was a weary ancient
outsider who showed up to help but had
almost no bedside manner to speak of
showrunner stephen moffat noted the new
iteration's coldness and he called
capaldi's doctor much fiercer madder and
less reliable than tenant or matt smith
the characters around the doctor
recognize his weakness as his run goes
on having to balance their plan of
attack against antagonists while knowing
that 12 is an adrenaline junkie who
loves to dive in with both feet
live by the moffat die by the moffett
matt smith's eccentric and noodly
performance as the doctor was
characterized by a head writer who loved
rousing speeches front loading his run
with memorable standoffs and scenery
chewing shouting matches however smith
was also in the main role when stephen
moffat spiraled the series into a
convoluted mess that couldn't just be
waved away with wiggly wobbly tiny
whimey
stuff for many of the episodes smith is
a perfect first doctor for the show's
intended audience
children his giddy joy over dinosaurs on
a spaceship and his wonder at seeing the
perseverance of people well into the
future makes him an ideal hero for a
child
i know
dinosaurs
on a spaceship
however much of that goodwill is
squandered by convoluted plotlines that
can be difficult to understand even as
an adult to follow the story of the
doctor amy and rory late in matt smith's
tenure was a good way to risk a
nosebleed but the highs of his first
appearance and a chills inducing stare
down between the doctor and every major
villain were worth the headache
if patrick trouten only managed to get
people on board with the idea of an
entirely new actor playing the doctor
and in only 150 episodes no less his
work would be admirable the fact that
treven went above and beyond that
securing a place above the original
actor in most fans hearts is remarkable
credit a shift in writing and costuming
to play detroit's strengths the
so-called cosmic hobo turned the doctor
from a lecturer to a lovable
space-faring [ __ ] troutman played the
doctor with the wide-eyed wonder you
might expect from someone who has the
ability to travel the entire universe
the hobo aesthetic leeched into the
script trodden's doctor got in and out
of stories much quicker than hartnell's
four-part historical epics cementing the
monster of the week style story that has
produced some of doctor who's most
thrilling hours trodden helped build the
antagonism between classic villains and
the doctor over his three series tenure
as he nearly always encountered a
villain every time he stepped out of the
police box
christopher eccleston gave us some idea
of how a longer run for john hurt's war
doctor would play out the first doctor
of the 2005 doctor who revival played
the character with all the weight of the
time war on his shoulders his outfit
reflected his brooding nature suiting
the alien traveler up in a leather
jacket and topping it off with an angry
stare his take on the doctor preceded
the grimdark era of genre movies but his
performance can be seen as an early
adopter of that gritty style in
particular he earns his dour attitude in
the modern classic episode the doctor
dances his harsh demeanor cracks when he
learns that his crew has managed to set
things right without causing death and
destruction in an instantly iconic
moment eccleston turns to the camera
with a maniacal grin on his face and
shouts
everybody lives bros
just this once
everybody lives
his tenure on who brought the show back
to life and that one crack allowed light
to shine into the series as they
barreled toward one of the series most
adored leads
for many people born in the late 80s on
david tennant is the doctor his affable
but confident turn as the doctor brought
a massive wave of new fans who certainly
weren't turned away by the fact that the
writing hit a high for knew who during
tenants time balancing the steady hand
of russell t davies with the bursts of
originality from stephen moffat tennant
was also buoyed by a murderer's row of
companions in billy piper's lovesick
rose catherine tate's wisecracking donna
and frima adjamen's intelligent and
assured martha tennant's run also
introduced the tragic plot of river song
and included several all-time great
episodes like blink and human nature
altogether the writing and cast paired
with a budget reflecting their suddenly
high ratings produced the best run of
the series since its revival
don't turn your back don't look away and
don't blink
tom baker what can we say if you're over
a certain age his woolly hair and long
scarf are bound to be the image in your
mind's eye when you recall the doctor
he's lodged there for more reasons than
the fact that he held the position
longer than any other actor though that
certainly doesn't hurt his case for best
doctor ever tom baker hit the perfect
balance between a compassionate and
humanistic leader and an odd outsider
with a whimsical view of the universe
baker handled everything from the
creeping horror of his early seasons to
the zippy and fantastical scripts penned
by legendary author douglas adams and
always from the comical horror camp of
the brain of morbius to the high
weirdness of city of death from canine
to romana baker's tenure highlighted
what the series does best even better he
did it with a grin on his face and jelly
babies in his hand
would you like a chili baby
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you